for many Americans each day they're told
to stay home from work due to the
coronavirus is a step closer to hardship
for example NBA stadium workers may
struggle now that the season is
suspended the Dallas Mavericks Mark
Cuban is one team owner vowing to
continue paying his workers he explained
why it's not just about the players
playing the sport there's so many people
that contribute the workers at the arena
people that do part-time work for the
Mavericks but they all work on an hourly
basis like 80 plus million people in
this country and when you're getting
paid by the hour there's a very good
chance that you know you're living
paycheck to paycheck and I and these are
people that that work for me directly or
indirectly and I just don't want to just
leave them hanging those Stadium workers
aren't alone in a recent survey 53% of
Americans said they do not have
emergency funds to cover a significant
amount of time without a paycheck CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
join us Jill good morning good morning
I'm following up on this I mean about
half of Americans live paycheck to
paycheck how do you prepare for
something like this which is we don't
know how long it's going to last I don't
think you can prepare at this point
you're in it and so what we've always
said when times are good you'd like to
have an emergency reserve on a rainy day
fund the rainy day has come if you don't
have this money I think the most
important thing that you can do right
this minute is to really conserve your
cash be very careful and I don't want
you to maybe not pay your rent and I
certainly don't want you to not pay a
critical bills but anything that's not
mission-critical you are conserving your
cash again this is truly a problem
because we know that a lot of financial
difficulties occur as a result of health
issues and here we have it right in our
faces
so what should the government be
considering I mean these proposals on
payroll tax cuts on unpaid leave to help
workers which should be the focus I
think the focus should be the people who
are most directly impacted so it's not a
payroll tax cut actually because those
people are working who are going to be
benefiting from that so we want to help
people who are those hourly employees we
want to have paid sick leave we want to
make sure that
people are floated the money you know a
fascinating thing that is happening is
that private industry is stepping in
where the government is not we're not
just Mark Cuban but we saw Walmart
extend its paid leave and remember about
a quarter of this country does not have
paid leave that's more than 30 million
Americans this is something where I
think we have to really flood the end
zone with cash for these people to help
them through this critical time all
right Joe thank you very much